pass à mundir qui a fait énormément
réagir aussi mon mundir hier hier on
recevait ellizabeth Levy dont les propos
avaient fait beaucoup parler le matin et
ensuite c'est mundir qui a fait parler
donc c'est vrai que ça a été il a voulu
lire une lettre c'est la première fois
que j'entends quelqu'un lire une lettre
dans cette émission c'était c'était
magnifique fait rent l'a fait aussi je
vais l'appeler Renand lu une lettre dans
laquelle mon revient sur l'histoire des
musulmans en France et cette lettre a
fait énormément réagir on va en parler
dans un instant avec Juliette Briance
qui est avec nous regardez si vous
n'avez pas vu mir hier ça ça a fait
beaucoup parler plusque ce que vous avez
dit effectivement c'est à vomir nous
musulmans on s'excuse c'est vrai on
s'excuse d'avoir sauvé la France lors de
la deuxème guerre mondiale conquise en 3
jours nous sommes allés au front avec
des prières qui visiblement ne
dérangeaient personne à cette époque-
làà pendant que la majorité des Français
collaborent bien à l'abri et qu'une
infine minorité de héros résistait
difficilement tant la délation svissait
en juillet 1944 nous musulmans madame
lesv on s'excuse car nous sommes allés
jusqu'à les accueillir et est protégé
dans notre pays d'origine pour finir
madame Lévi vous quê essiste il y a il y
a quelqu'un qui s'appelle Albert Camu
que j'aime beaucoup et il dit que la
bêtise insiste toujours alors il faut
laisser parler voilà Juliette est avec
nous Juliette brance directeur de la
communication magazine l'incorrect
influenceuse patriote merci d'être là
vous avez pensé quoi de la lre de mundir
hier euh elle m'a beaucoup
choqué déjà j'ai trouvé le ton assez
désastreux c'est-à-dire que quand on
demande à une dame qui s'appelle Levy et
qui vient en plus de visionner 45
minutes image atroce sur les actes
terroristes du Hamas du 7 octobre si
dascho et la guestapo ça lui dit quelque
chose Bahmi vous dire que c'est
légèrement sordide mais au-delà de ça et
du ton général
euh bah tout était faux quoi tout était
faux pratiquement ou en tout cas la
quasi totalité était faux alors les
musulmans ont sauvé la France mais je
suis désolé mais faut faut faut
dégonfler son melon quoi à un moment
donné je ne sais pas où vous êtes allé à
l'école ou qui vous a appris ça mais il
faut dégonfler son melon les musulmans
n'ont jamais sauvé la France les
musulmans morts ça représente sans les
musulmans ça représente 100000 morts sur
les deux guerres mondiales sur les deux
guerres mondiales donc ces gens sont
venus ils sont morts pour la France et
on on les remercie mais rien qu'à la
Première Guerre mondiale il y a eu
1300000 morts donc les musulmans n'ont
pas sauvé la France vous voyez ce que je
veux dire ensuite les musulmans ont
sauvé la France pendant que les Français
étaient chez eux tapis à collaborer mais
vous prenez pour qui mais vous crachez
mais mais sur les Français sur toutes
leur mémoire la collaboration les
historiens l'estiment entre 2 à 5 % en
France Jean Moulin il est pas né à Raba
d'accord Charles de Gaulle pareil c'est
un français donc c'est pas les musulmans
qui ont sauvé la France c'est les
Français qui ont sauvé la France et les
Alliés je poursuis quand vous dites que
les Français ont réparé pareil les
Français pardon les musulmans ont réparé
la France pendant les tres glorieuses
mais pendant les 30 glorieuses au pic
les les les comment dire les les
étrangers dans le BTP ils représentaient
30 % et parmi ces 30 % la majorité était
des Italiens et des Portugais et et des
Espagnols et les les maghrébains donc
les musulmans
représenta ne représentait en tout que 6
% de de de des des des gens dans le
BTP à l'époque des tromes glorieuses
donc c'est pareil qui est-ce qui vous a
appris que les musulmans ont reconstruit
la France alors que c'est faux et la
dernière chose et après j'arrête quand
on parle d'histoire euh c'est bien vous
pouvez voir la préttenion de parler
d'histoire et vous avez par exemple vous
avez cité l'imam de la mosquée de Paris
qui
effectivement aurait sauvé des Juifs
aurait abrité des Juifs mais faut parler
de tout à ce niveau-là à ce compte- là
il faut parler de tout parce que alors
déjà on vous a jamais demandé de vous
excuser ça c'est la première chose
personne ne vous a jamais demandé de
vous excuser et puis vous avez été très
sélectif parce que vous avez jamais
parlé par exemple des 200000 musulmans
en uniforme allemand qu'on a recensé en
43 vous n'avez jamais parlé des
divisions de SS entières composé de
musulmans dans les Balcans vous n'avez
pas parlé du mfti de Jérusalem qui avait
des relations très étroites avec avec
Hitler et qui a empêché des des milliers
de Juifs des pays de l'Est de s'exiler
enfin de fuir en Palestine pour pour
éviter les camps et vous avez pas dit
que dans tous les pays arabo mususulmans
en ce moment mcamp fa un Bestseller qui
se vend extrêmement bien bien bien en
plus c'est même pas comparable que dans
les pays occidentaux et vous n'avez vous
l'avez balayé d'un revers de main jamais
écouter Élisabeth Lévi quand elle vous a
dit que depuis 30 ans voir plus tous les
morts tous les morts juifs tués parce
qu'ils sont juifs l'ont été par la main
de musulmans mais je sais que c'est dur
à entendre mais c'est une simple vérité
Koulibali Mera tous nos attentats Miriam
knol Sarah limi enfin on pourrait en
citer plein et vous pouvez pas m'en
citer un qui n'a pas à voir avec avec
l'islam mais donc voà et encore une fois
ellizabeth Lévy que vous avez agressé
sans raison n'avait jamais dit que tous
les musulmans étaient antisémites elle a
dit qu'il y avait un problème de
surreprésentation en ce moment dans
l'islam avec l'antisémitisme et c'est
tout voilà m qu'est-ce queon non je
trouve ça toujours très intéressant
d'être jugé par l'extrême
droite d'accord merci si vous que ça
répondre je je finis je finis mais tous
les deux je vous prends il y a aucun
problème euh alors moi je suis
responsable de ce que je dis pas mais je
suis pas responsable attends tu dis quoi
tous les deux c'est qui
non tous les deux je
prends par toi aussi je te prends donc
pour le pour le coup pour le coup moi je
suis responsable de ce que je dis mais
je suis pas responsable de ce que de ce
que les gens pensent donc je je parle en
connaissance de cause je parle d'une
certaine histoire qui a eu lieu
visiblement on n'est pas d'accord
là-dessus euh en temp normal je me
mélange jamais avec avec l'extrême
droite je suis allé je vous connaissais
pas je suis allé voir effectivement ce
que vous faisiez je suis tombé sur sur
sur votre profil profil Twitter d'accord
et là je lis en plus vous likez vous
avez liké
ça donc d'un de vos fans elle a un
plateau d'arabe en face d'elle des
islamistes car oui la majorité des
musulmans en France est islamiste c'est
une minorité qui ne l'est pas bon ça
c'est làdessus et ensuite il y en a un
autre qui dit
et vous avez massacré les nôtres lors
des attentats et vous massacrez les nôes
chaque jour pour revenenir à ce que vous
me
disiez je vi vous faire une DI vous
allez répondre à rien je suis juste
d'trme drite tout attendez vous me dites
que j'ai agressé madame
l est- que je peux
finirépz je je réponds à ce qu' dit je
suis en train de dire que vous me dites
que vous avez que j'ai agressé madame l
je n absolument pas agresser madame léi
j'ai répondu justement à une attaque
qu'elle dit en disant qu'elle stigmatise
les musulmans qui sont tous antisémit
elle a pas dit ça fois une seule fois
elle a pas dit ça une seule fois elle a
dit que la majorité la majorité des ACT
elle a dit que la majorité des fois où
les Juifs se sentaient en D ça prevenait
d'AC qui venait de gens musulmans et
après elle a dit trois fois pendant le
plateau que elle répétait encore une
fois que tout les musulmans n'étaient
pas antisémites et loin de là c'était
une Minit pas Madame elle dit elle l'
dit d'accord mais en tout cas pas
d'accord mais c'est juste dire c'est
factuel vousz répondu mes arguments que
je viens de vous exposer ce soir vous
m'avez juste répondu que j'étais
d'extrême droite et vous m'avez sorti
des tweets de Random là que
personne mais c'est moi qui écr ça c'est
moi
qui sur le reste ça prouve que il y a
des Algériens des indigènes qui sont
venus com oui c'est ce que vous avez dit
vous avez dit les musulmans ont sauvé la
France pendant que les Français
collaboraient c'est ça que vous avez dit
je je non je je n non madame je n'ai pas
à cracher seulement ça c'est votre
interprétation ce n'est pas la mienne je
suis en train de vous dire qu'il y a
effectivement des indigènes musulmans
qui ont au péril de leur vie SAU la FR
jamais pas une seis pas une seule fois
laisse mundir reparler non parce que
voulait parler M dire qu'est-ce que tu
voulez dire je dis tout simplement que
ceux qui rêvent qu'il y a une opposition
entre les Juifs de France et les
musulmans de France ben c'est à eux de
quitter la France tout simplement pardon
quoi c'est au français de quitter la
France non je suis en train de dire ceux
qui rêvent ceux qui rêvent que les Juifs
et les musulmans s'entretuent c'est eux
qui n'aiment pas la France tout
simplement c'est pas la France que je
mais qui mais qui rêve de ça mais vous
êtes à côté de la place absol pas je
suis absolument pas côté de la répond à
mais je réponds que il me répond à rien
donc je ne sais pas quoi répondre
qu'est-ce que voule répondre vous avez
répondu à rien j'ai jamais dit que je
voulais que les juifs et les musulmans
s'entretuent j'ai jamais dit qu' avait
pas de tir avait pas de combattant
musulmans je les ai même cité j'ai dit
qu'il y en avait eu 100000 mais ce
n'était donc pas la majorité loin
de bah si vous avez dit les musulmans
sauv la France mais alors c'est pas
forcment qu je
dis
AG pas AG sur un ton courtois je n
absolument pas
dis j'ai pas l je dis parce Mo parle
lesamp concentration ça me parle mais je
n'ai pas dit et tout
çaose vous êes F de vous mie juste vous
comprenez les réactions qu' a eu parce
qu'il y a eu des réactions il des bonnes
réactions il des mauvaises réactions sur
sur ce qui s'est passé hier sur la
phrase deabeth lev non non de de ce qui
s'est passé hier bah oui moi je
comprends que j'ai été outré donc je ou
je vous aviez tweé làdus mais vraiment
j'étais mal à l'aise j'étais mal à
l'aise parce qu'en plus elle est venue
je trouve dans une démarche très honnête
et sincère où elle voulait vraiment
faire part d'un mal-être et c'est le
mal-être de la communauté juive en ce
moment et son malêtre il est il est
justifié ou pas alors ça vous ça je vous
laisse l'apécier moi je pense que je
pense que oui elle venait de visionner
mais 45 minutes d'horreur elle avait
encore la la main qui tremblait ça se
voyait et elle s'est fait mais traité de
tous les noms sur ce plateau de raciste
d'islamophobe et cetera parce qu'elle
était une inquiétude une inquiétude qui
est d'ailleurs beaucoup partagé par les
Juifs qui qui qui s'exodent par exemple
vous avez jamais dit non plus que au 20e
siècle il y a eu un exode de 800000
Juifs de tous les pays musulmans qui son
par j'ai parlé 2 minutes madame j'ai
parlé de bah vous avez écrit une lettre
vous ariez pu l' mais justement donc je
l' dit donc voilà mais pas du tout
attendez laissez-moi finir donc moi j'ai
2 minutes donc j'ai dis ce que j'avais à
dire estce que j'ai dit était sincère
vrai tout simplement à partir du moment
où effectivement il se passe des choses
en France quoi tu rigoles frère c'est
lui mon sort
j'ai fait quoi tu sors j'ai rien fait
sors oui allez vas-y nous on dire non
c'est tombé non non mais vas-y vas-y
c'est
bon vous vous sentez mal aussi pas du
tout s bien je vous rassure tout je suis
très très bien suis très très bien
j'assume ce que j'ai dit j'assume ce que
je dis totalement que je dis en j'ai
répondu de ce que
je répondre plusard tu me dis
répondassume ce que je dis
et
mus ce que j'assume pas madame je pas
répondre par par non faire plaisir ce
que j'assume pas M
en fait vous savez en parlant de victime
il y a 1500 actes antisémites depuis le
7 octobre et on a
l'impressionou y a 1500 actes antisémite
depuis le 7 octobre et si on vous écoute
on a l'impression que les victimes c'est
les musulmans trouvez pas un mais vous
trouvez pas ça un hier hier vous nous
avez fait à 1000 larmes ENF c'était des
larmes à larmes vous étiez là en train
de nous expliquer com les
musul hos et VI j si je peux me
permettre de de de de parler pour Bir m
en fait ce qui ce qui voulait dire je
pense hier et ce qu'il veut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que lui il veut pas
que le comme l'a dit Gérard darin que le
le
conflitexor s'exporte ici et que lui il
a pas envie que ce soit la guerre entre
les musulmans les Juifs entre ses potes
entre sa famille puisquil a de la
famille c'est ce que c'est ce qu' a
voulu direir je pense que c'est ça qu'
voulait dire c'est pour ça que je dis je
dis ceux qui veulent opposer c'est ça
que je voulais dire é qui veulent
opposer les Juifs de France et les
musulmans de France Mame
par actu passe actuellement ce qui se
passe actuellement on veut opposer de
communautés qui s'entendent très très
bien si
Madame
pasinentend très très bien faut voyager
un petit peu et vous
ver PAL en Israël pas très bien pouro
par y a des musul ça fait que du mal de
ne pas nommer les choses arrêtez de dire
qu' s très bien pas vous étiz mais moi
moi ici j'ai dénoncé j'ai dénoncé et je
fais du terin c'est la moindre des
choses je pas vous dire bravo c'est la
MO des chos je suis pas en train de vous
dire bravo bon B alors mais arrêtez de
me dire qu'il y a aucun problème entre
les Juifs et les musulmans en ce moment
enfin enfin ça relève vraiment y a il y
a un grave problème à Gaza et en Israël
et non pas du tout donc les 1500 actes
depuis
le jeé
mag se coup mais maintenant l'ensemble
des Juifs français et l'ensemble des
musulm musulmans français s'entendent
très très bien sur la phrase d'hier tu
te sens pas mal à l'aise le fait de dire
à Elizabeth
léi de demander à quelqu'un s'il connait
Gestapo juste cette phrase là est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui je te réponds
que tu me fais le même coup qu'avec
l'imam lorsque je dis à Isabelle Lévi
madameab pardonisabeth l lorsque je lui
dis est-ce que Daso ça vous parle c'est
parce que ça me par parle d'accord voilà
PARP ça me parle mais là effectivement
toi tu viens tu viens de haer tu viens
tu viens de hausser la la tête ça prouve
que finalement tu me crois pas mais je
suis en train de te dire quand je parle
de dascho ça me parle et les C de la
mort ça me parle je dis pas que ça te
parle pas non mais moi c'était ça quand
je est-ce que ça vous par
par dire c'est que c'est pas très de
dire çaabeth c'est ça tu veux j'aurais
pu dire ça me parle est-ce que ça vous
parle comme moi ça me parle c'est
peutêtre ça arrangé c'est ça le dire
comme ça ça n'a rien à voir donc c'est
ça comme ça je souffle un peu depuis
tout à l'heure pourquoi alors j'ai juste
soufflé parce que je me suis dit mince
il part très très
mal l'accuser tout de suite d'extrême
droite avec ce qu'elle a dit avec
beaucoup de vérité j'ai voilà c'est pour
ça donc si tu l'as mal pris excuse-m
pas en revanche je trouve que tu as été
prêt je crois ta sincérité je crois en
ta sincérité il y a pas de problème je
pense que hier ce que tu as fait c'est
exactement ce que tu reprochais à
éizabeth Lévi qui pose un vrai problème
problème ça se discute mais elle pose un
vrai problème en disant que il y a un
problème d'antisémitisme avec les
musulmans il y a pas que les néonazis de
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui pose un problème
en ce moment d'antisémitisme c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut mettre sur la
table elle a choqué hier mais c'était
bien qu'elle choque et et toi tu lui
disais qu'elle elle globalisait et que
tous les musulmans étaient antisémites
tu et là tu fais exactement pareil dans
ta lettre tu as fait exactement pareil
nous musulmans on a sauvé la France
pendant que la majorité des Français
collaborent tu fais exactement la même
chose justement j'ai été à l'inverse
j'ai été à l'inverse quand je dis nous
musulmans on s'excuse c'est justement
pour dire que tous les musulmans en
France ne sont pas antisémit et la
France n'est pas tombée en 3 jours pard
la France n'est pas tombée en 3 jours ni
en qu d'accord mais vous avez dit la
France est tombée en 3
jours le BL c'est juste
uneoui c'est une guerre rapide la France
n'est pas tombé en 3 jours pe importe
d'accord la drôle de guerre elle a duré
8 mois enfin voilà donc non mais en fait
vous AZ dit
littéralement rien à renir de vrai dans
tout ce que vous avez dit de toute votre
diatp pourtant vous l'aviez écrite vous
l'aviez écrite voyz moi j'ai même pas de
note il y a un élément qui est vrai
c'est que la la la Grande Mosquée de
Paris a sauvé
1732 132 Ju 1732 Juifs pendant ansit
d'ailleurs je suis pas en train
d'essayer de minimiser les bonnes
actions des musulmans qui sont morts
pour la France ou qui se sont se sont
battus avec vérité pour la France mais
c'est pas du tout mon mon projet par
contre vous par contre vous vous avez
effacé tout ce qu'on
faitond respect pour la
résist qui sont sur la fr
fr sur les plaques commémorativ dans les
villages a pas écrit mundir 100 fois
vraiment
non musulmans sauvé la France moi je
vois je vois pas beaucoup de
mundir en une fois redescendons il
s'agit pas encore une fois de minimiser
les actes HRO musul sont pour la
France vre histoire frement cétait disé
ça vraiment ça choqué tout le monde
[Musique]
Mo non mais je suis un
peu je suis un peu dégoûté par Madame
mais respectueusement parce qu'on prend
un cours d'hoire de votre part euh qui
euh émane effectivement d'une partie de
l'extrême droite euh qui est extrêmement
vindicatif contre les musulmans et
d'autre part la seule erreur de mundir
ce sont les chiffres que vous avez
repris d'accord mais là vous êtes en
train de faire ce que fait madame non
mais vous êtes en train de faire ce que
fait madame Lévy c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
vous minorez totalement le rôle des
musulmans pendant la guerre vous êtes en
train d'effacer vous l'histoire des
musulmans en FR fait très bien
derrière j'ai même pas dit un mot
derrière l'habileté de votre rétorique
il y a les 100000 musulmans on les
efface les Marocains qui ont libéré la
Corse en 1943 on s'en fout vous êtes en
train de balayer l'apport et l'impact
des musulmans en France au nom de vos
croyances et ça c'est dégueulasse que
vous faites à mir c'est
dégueulasse RP je l'ai répété au moins
trois fois il ne s'agit absolument pas
de
les actes héroïques de tous ces
musulmans qui sont morts pour la France
répéter répéter tro fois et là vous me
dites vous minorez ok bon alors en
faitien à vous dire Monsieur si vous
pastrme droite j'ai juste dit ma vérité
et une vérité en fait factuelle parce
que contrairement à Monsieur je connais
mon histoire et puis c'est tout quoi ENF
j'ai rien dit d'extrême droite- que vous
avez lui dire à part ça parce tout est
fa dans ce qu'elle dit c elle manipule
tout elle prend TR
chiffres elle va dire bientôt elle a
minimisé totalement le rôle des alliés
pendant la libération c'estàd que pour
vous ce sont les Français qui sont
révoltés contre l'EM vous avez cité les
chiffres des collaborationnistes 100000
on est d'accord entre 2 et 5 % mais ce
sont les alliés qui nous ont sauvé c'est
mais vous savez très bien vous réécrivez
l'histoire à l'OND de vos croyan musult
sauvé non plus c'est pas plus les
musulmans que les non musulmans mais
c'est pas moins les musulmans tu te
trompes sur un point c'est que c'est les
réseaux catholiques qui étaient les plus
puissants en matière de de résistance et
qui ont organiser une partie de la
résistance les communistes évidemment
mais les réseau le réseau catholique via
les diocèses via via tout le tout tout
tout le tout ce qui était en place les
écoles les religieux et cetera bien plus
que d'autres
confessions pour finir non mais pour
finir voilà moi je je suis venu dire ma
vérité défendre Elisabeth Levi aussi
parce que vraiment j'ai été touchée j'ai
été touché par le le traitement qu'elle
a reçu ici j'ai trouvé que j'ai trouvé
totalement in et voilà et donc pour
terminer pour termin
personneta personne qui lui a manqué de
respect alors nous alors alors je va
vous dire sil vous plaît s' plaî plaî
nous à long nous quand on est on était
sur le plateau on l' pas ça a priori qui
éé ce qui a été ressenti c'est qu'il y
avait une meute contre elle
contreisabeth ceux qui étent contre elle
qui ont parlé exactement c'est ça parce
que ellisabeth elle est tellement mine
de rien est tellement forte que j' me
dit voilà s'est pris islamophobe et
raciste dans la tête quand
même et il a eu l'impression qu'il y
avait que des gens qui étaient contre
Elisabeth Levi mais comme j'ai fait
parler que ceux qui étaient contre
Elisabeth Levi parce que forcément
Elisabeth Levi elleess défendre tout
seulment ça a donné l'impression d'un
plateau hostile contre elle voilà mais
voir c'est mundir et Gill qui ont parlé
ensemble mais quand vous avez voilà
c'est Gill verd il est contre tout le
monde non c'est pas ça c mais juste ahon
je voulais juste te dire on pourrait
rendre hommage à tous les Marocains les
tirailleurs sénégalais les Algériens qui
on contribué à sauver la France répond à
arrêtez on tout le temps c'est bon ce
qu' vient de dire on fait tout le temps
c'est
bon merci à tous allez tout
suite